the protests against the taliban have
moved on to the streets of the capital
the afghan flag is the popular sign of
descent
from jalalabad kabul it is a deliberate
snub to the white flag that the taliban
has raised over town and city squares
the protests are mostly peaceful for now
but how long will the taliban let it
continue
until the taliban accepts that today's
afghanistan is different to afghanistan
20 years ago and convince us that they
have changed and they won't go back to
their same system the taliban should
come and kneel before us we will never
kneel before
them if they truly love their country
they will not fear us this country is
ours we will save it by all means
afghan women are slowly being rubbed out
of society this was a beauty salon in
kabul today the taliban leadership
insists women will be free to live their
lives but evidence to the contrary is
mounting
we had an
announcement from the taliban that we
have nothing with the woman
you can continue your work as you were
working previously
but you know one of my friend who is a
an answer in national tv she was she she
was not allowed to do her job
[Music]
the number of women protesting on the
streets despite the obvious and real
dangers to them is quite something
they perhaps have most to fear the
taliban warriors against women they
don't want a woman to be educated
educated they take away the rights from
the woman the first thing they do they
take away everything from a woman
another raf aircraft has landed at an
air base in dubai
and in qatar the faces say it all
interpreters and their families have
been arriving in the gulf state but
there is still more tragedy than hope in
all this
zaki and wari played football for
afghanistan earlier this week his young
body was found in the landing gear of a
u.s air force plane
he was just 19 years old and a talented
sportsman
he died trying to escape the country he
once proudly represented
alastair bunker sky news